QUORUM.
SO WE'LL START AS A SUB
COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE A TOTAL OF TWENTY ONE
BILLS ON THE AGENDA TODAY.
OTHER TEN ITEMS ON THE PROPOSED
CONSENT CALENDAR DOES INCLUDE
ITEM FOR A. B..
TWO SEVENTY FIVE ITEM SEVEN AB.
SIX OH NINE NINE A BEETLE TO
ADAM TWELVE AB.
TEN EIGHTY TWO ITEM -- FOURTEEN
AB.
ELEVEN SIXTY SIX ITEM SIXTEEN
FOURTEEN SEVENTY THREE ITEM.
EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN TEN BY THE
NINETEEN EIGHTEEN TWENTY FIVE I
AM.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN TWENTY SIX ITEM.
TWENTY ONE EIGHTEEN TWENTY SEVEN
IF YOU DIDN'T CATCH THE THEME
THOSE ARE ALL AB SO -- SO WITH
THAT -- I SEE THAT -- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW IS HERE AND WE'RE
GOING TO DO AB ONE THIRTY THAT
WOULD BE ITEM NUMBER. TWO GOOD
MORNING ASSEMBLY MEMBER GOOD
MORNING MR CHEN MEMBERS THIS IS
AB -- ONE THIRTY WHICH IS THE
OFFICE OF HIGHER ED DID WHICH
THAT THIS COMMITTEE HAS VOTED IN
SUPPORT BEFORE FOR SOFT LIKE
TODAY THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
TO HELP ESTABLISH A PERFORMANCE.
ON CORNING ANTI OF HIGHER
EDUCATION RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FIRST
WITNESS AND SUPPORT YES GOOD
MORNING CHAIR DOT IN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEES THERE ARE SEE ON
BEHALF OF THE CAMPAIGN FOR
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY.
WE ARE A STATE WIDE POLICY AND
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION DEDICATING
TO ENSURING ALL CALIFORNIANS
HAVE AN EQUAL OPPORTUNITY TO
ATTEND AND SUCCEED IN COLLEGE --
WE KNOW THAT IN THE COMING YEARS
CALIFORNIA WILL BE A GROWING
SUPPLY OF EDUCATED WORKERS TO
MEET THE DEMANDS OF OUR ECONOMY.
AND KEEP US A FEELING THIS IS
GOING TO BE SERVING MANY MARK
STUDENTS IN OUR HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEM AND ENSURING THE ACCESS
AND SUCCESS THE POPULATIONS THAT
HAVE HISTORICALLY BEEN UNDER
REPRESENTED -- YET CALIFORNIA
CURRENTLY STANDS OUT AS ONE OF
TWO STATES WITHOUT A STATEWIDE
COORDINATING BODY.
OF FOR HIGHER EDUCATION MEETING
WE LACKED THE STATE LEVEL
LEADERSHIP NECESSARY FOR
PLANNING OVERSIGHT COORDINATION --
TO POSITION THE STATE TO MEET
THESE CHALLENGES SO WE SUPPORT
AB ONE THIRTY BECAUSE IT FEELS
IS CRITICAL VOID.
AND ESTABLISHES THAT STATE LEVEL
LEADERSHIP NEEDED TO MEET THOSE
FUTURE WORK FORCE DEMANDS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
HANNAH BRAG START WITH THE CAL
STATE STUDENT ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
THE MORNING AVAILABLE UNTIL THE
PUBLIC ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT.
GIVE ME WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NINE ANY QUESTIONS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHEN WE HAVE A
QUORUM WE WILL BE VOTING ON THIS
BILL.
MAYBE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD AB THIRTY
EIGHT THAT'S ITEM NUMBER.
ONE THANK ORDER DODD MISTER
CHAIR HIS MAIN MEMBERS.
IN OCTOBER TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN THE TUBS FIRE STARTED
IN CALISTOGA IN IN UNDER FOUR
HOURS WEB TWELVE MILES THROUGH
SOME ACCOUNTING INTO THE CITY OF
SANTA ROSA.
AT THE TIME WE FELT THAT AS OF
THIS WE HAD EXPERIENCE A ONCE IN
A GENERATION TRAGEDY AND SINCE
THEN WE'VE HAD THE THOMAS FIRE
THE WOLSEY CAR WHICH IN
CAMPFIRES.
WHICH OF ALL SADLY PROVEN US
WRONG WE NOW UNDERSTAND THESE
CATS CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES ARE
PART OF THE NEW ABNORMAL.
WE'RE STARTING TO COME TO TERMS
WITH THE SCALE OF THE PROBLEM WE
HAVE ON OUR HANDS.
LAST YEAR IN SB NINE A ONE WE
COMMITTED SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES
TO IMPROVE THE HEALTH OF OUR
FORESTS AND WHILE LANCE WHICH IS
CRITICAL TO OUR CLICK BIGGER
CLIMATE CHANGE PICTURE.
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE OVER TWO
MILLION HOMES ALREADY BUILT IN
HIGH OR VERY HIGH FIRE HAZARD
SEVERITY ZONES AND THESE
COMMUNITIES ARE IN IMMINENT
DANGER.
CURRENT BUILDING CODES REQUIRE
NEW CONSTRUCTION TO UTILIZE
MATERIALS LANDSCAPING AND
DESIGNS THAT HELP PREVENT WELL
WINDBLOWN EMBERS FROM IGNITING
BUILDING TO SPREADING THROUGH
NEIGHBORHOODS HOWEVER THE VAST
MAJORITY OF HOMES WE'RE THE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WITH WERE
BUILT LONG BEFORE.
THESE CODES WENT INTO PLACE.
AB THIRTY EIGHT IS OUR ATTEMPT
TO BEGIN ADDRESSING THE HUGE
CHALLENGE OF PREPARING THIS
OLDER BUILT ENVIRONMENT FOR THE
FIRES OF THE NEW CLIMATE CHANGE
HERE UP.
IN THIS BILL WE ARE PROPOSING A
TWO PRONGED APPROACH FIRST WE'RE
PROPOSING A REBATE OR NO WE'RE
LOW INTEREST REVOLVING LOAN FUND
TO HELP PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
RESOURCES FOR HOMEOWNERS. TO
RETROFIT HOMES IN VERY HIGH FIRE
HAZARD SEVERITIES OWNS THE FUND
WILL BE OPERATED BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE WIDE
COMMUNITIES DEVELOPMENT
AUTHORITY.
SECONDLY REQUIRING HOMEOWNERS IN
VERY HIGH HAZARD SEVERITIES OWES
DISCLOSE WHICH FIRE HARDENING
RETROFITS ARE NEEDED TO PROTECT
HOME FOR WINDBLOWN EMBERS AND
REVISED PROOF OF THIS IS OF A
SUCCESSFUL DEFENSIBLE SPACE
INSPECTION WHEN I'M HOME IS SOLD.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH
THE OPPOSITION TO ENSURE THE
REQUIREMENTS DO NOT HAVE THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE.
OF PREVENTING HOMEOWNERS FROM
SELLING THEIR HOMES I'M
OPTIMISTIC THAT BEFORE THE BILL
REACHES THE FOR WILL FIND THE
BALANCE THAT CREATES FLEXIBILITY
FOR WOULD BE HOME SELLERS.
AND INCREASES THE INSPECTION AND
RETROFIT RATES OF HOMES IN
DANGER OF CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES.
CENTERS IS NOT A SILVER BULLET
IT'S TAKEN AS GENERATIONS TO GET
IN TO THE SITUATION IT WILL TAKE
US YEARS TO GET OUT BUT I
BELIEVE AB THIRTY EIGHT MOVES IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
HERE TESTIFIED SUPPORT IS LIZ
FORSBERG WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR IBM.
PLEASE.
MAYBE MY NAME IS LIZ FORSBERG
LEMME SOCI TRACTOR POLICY FOR
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY.
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY IS AN
ACTIVE MEMBER OF THE FIRE
ADOPTED COMMUNITIES LEARNING
NETWORK A NATIONAL GROUP WORKING
TO BUILD SUSTAINABLE WILDFIRE
RESILIENCE CAPACITY IN FIRE
PRONE COMMUNITIES.
AND WE ARE HERE TODAY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB.
THIRTY EIGHT CALIFORNIANS
EXPERIENCE THE WORST WILD WILD
FIRES IN HISTORY SETTING NEW
RECORDS FOR THE LARGEST AND MOST
DESTRUCTIVE.
AND AS THE MAKE A FIRE TREND
CONTINUES TO WORSEN IT IS
CRITICAL THAT WE MAKE ALL
COMMUNITIES AND HIGH FIRE HAZARD
REGION'S MORE RESILIENT.
WELL WE CAN'T STOP THIS PROGRAM
PROBLEM OVERNIGHT THERE ARE TWO
THINGS WE NEED TO INVEST IN
IMMEDIATELY TO BETTER PROTECT
PEOPLE AND NATURE IN THE FACE OF
WILDFIRE.
FORCED RESTORATION AND COMMITTEE
FIRE PROTECTION.
LAST YEAR CALIFORNIA MADE A ONE
BILLION DOLLAR COMMITMENT TO
FOREST HEALTH AND FEELS
REDUCTIONS OVER THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS.
WE NEED TO COMPARE BOWL
INVESTMENT IN COMMUNITY
PROTECTION TO ADOPT OUR HOMES TO
DEAL WITH THE ESCALATING THREATS
OF FIRE.
THE FIRE HARDENED HOMES
REVOLVING LOAN FUND CREATED IN
AB THIRTY EIGHT WILL HELP US
REACH THIS GOAL BY PROVIDING
RESOURCES TO HOMEOWNERS TO
RETROFIT HOMES FOR FIRE.
IN ADDITION AB THIRTY EIGHT WILL
ENSURE COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
STATE WILL HAVE THE CAPACITY TO
IMPROVE FIRE RESILIENCE.
THE BILL WILL IDENTIFY WHICH
COUNTIES NEED MORE RESOURCES AND
TECHNICAL EXPERTISE TO IMPROVE
FIRE SAFETY.
AND A DOCTOR COMMUNITIES TO DEAL
WITH THE ESCALATING THREATS OF
FIRE.
LET'S STOP MAKING HISTORY AND
START FIXING THE PROBLEM THROUGH
BOLD MEASURES LIKE AB.
THIRTY EIGHT WE THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WHAT FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
ON THE ISSUE AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS RHYME
PARINI WAS SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON WANT TO THANK THE MEMBER
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS
IMPORTANT BILL WE SEE AB.
THIRTY EIGHT AS A CRITICAL PIECE
TO THE BROADER WILDFIRE PUZZLE
AND HAPPY SUPPORT THIS MEASURE
THANK YOU.
SO THAT THAT WOULD COME OUT A
SHAREHOLDER FUNDS THEN RIGHT I'M
JUST TEASING YOU.
GO AHEAD NEXT DICK SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MARK
FENSTER MAKER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICTS
IN SUPPORT I WOULD SUPPORT THAT.
AMENDMENT MISTER CHECK.
THE FUTURE PLEASE ART RIGHT.
I HAD TO GO THERE [inaudible]
WHAT?
OTHER -- THE WITNESSES
OPPOSITION.
I WE HAVE A CENTER ARE TO LET IT.
AT THE END OF FOR OKAY.
CENTER HUESO PLEASE.
THANK YOU -- I JUST WANTED TO
SAY.
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT BILL.
AND OTHERS A NEW STATE OF
AFFAIRS IN CALIFORNIA THAT WE WE
CAN IGNORE.
GIVEN CLIMATE CHANGE AND THE
INTENSITY OF THESE FIRES AND I
KNOW.
IT IT'S GOING TO BRING A LITTLE
BIT OF THE CONVENIENCE FOR A FEW
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO FILE
THESE REPORTS.
THIS UNFORTUNATELY NEEDS TO
HAPPEN IN OUR STATE AND I HOPE.
THE PEOPLE OF SEE THIS AS A VERY
IMPORTANT NECESSARY MEASURE FOR
EVERYBODY'S WEALTHY IN AND AND
THE WELL BEING OF OF OUR STATE --
AND THIS IS GONNA BE CONSIDERED
ONE OF A PART OF THE PACKAGE
THAT WERE WERE VOTING ON AVENUE
DEAL WITH.
REDUCE IN -- THE AMOUNT OF FUEL
IN IT OUT THERE IN TE STATE WE
NEED EVERYBODY BE PART OF THIS
WE NEED THE INSURANCE COMPANIES
WE NEED.
THE STATE WE NEED CAL FIRE WE
NEED PROPERTY OWNERS WE NEED
EVERYBODY INVOLVED.
IN THIS MASSIVE -- STATEWIDE
EFFORT IN THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT BILLS I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR TAKING THE SONG.
AND AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME SURE
ONE MOVE THE STUFF THANK YOU
CENTER ARE TO LET UP.
YES THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN IT IS A
EXTREMELY.
IMPORTANT TO BILL AND WE'RE SO
HAPPY I AM THAT THAT YOU BROUGHT
BROUGHT THIS FORWARD.
IN YOUR OPENING STATEMENT YOU
HAD MENTIONED THAT YOU WORK WITH
THE OPPOSITION AND SHOW ON AND I
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS I WOULD
HAVE AND I'M SU MEAN YOU'RE
WORKING IT OUT WERE YOU ALREADY
HAVE AND THAT IS.
YOU'VE GOT A BUYER YOU GOT A
SELLER IN THE SELLER -- IS --
SEEKING TO SELL SURE HE WILL GO
AHEAD AND ASK FOR AN INSPECTION
OF SOME SORT SEE EXACTLY WHERE
IT STANDS.
AND THEN I WOULD IMAGINE THAT HE
WOULD DISCLOSED TO THE BUYER.
THAT THE HOUSE IS NOT --
RETROFITTED THE HOUSE DOES NOT
HAVE THAT FIREPROOF ROOF.
AND THE ADDICT IS NOT SECURE
FROM MEMBERS COMING IN AND TO
CONSEQUENTLY THE BUYER AT THAT
POINT WOULD HAVE FULL KNOWLEDGE.
WALK INTO THE TRANSACTION AND
SECURE THE HOME BUT THEN HIS --
ABLE TO GET A HOME LOAN A
REVOLVING LOAN WHICH WOULD PAY
FOR THE THE UPGRADES THAT ARE
NEEDED.
AND AT A LOW INTEREST RATE AND
SO ON AND EVEN TO SOME POINT A
REBATE WILL BE GIVEN.
SO IT WOULD BE IT -- IT SHOULD
BE A VERY ENTHUSIASTIC BUYER TO
BE ABLE. TO TO RETROFIT IS HOME
AND FOR FIRE SAFETY -- ENDED.
AND I'M ASSUMING ALONG THE WAY
IF A HOMEOWNER HAS NO -- THOUGHT
OF SELLING THAT HE WOULD ALSO BE
ELIGIBLE FOR THIS -- REBATE AND
LOAN AND AND JUST MAINTAIN HIS
HOME FOR YEARS TO COME.
SO BOTH SIDES I THINK -- THE
CONSUMERS PROTECTED AND SCHUMER
HAD RECEIVED INFORMATION.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY WE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA ARE GOING TO PREVENT
A FIRE.
IN HAVE PREVENTED FROM FIRE FROM
SPREADING SO THAT WE WORK WITH
THOSE ARE THE TWO OPPOSITION.
THAT YOU I THINK YOU NAILED IT --
WE THAT IS THAT IS THE PATH WE
HAVE TAKEN AND AS YOU SEE THERE
WAS NO THERE WAS NO OPPOSITION.
AS TO FIGHT TODAY AND WILL
CONTINUE WORKING WITH FOLKS I
THINK THE DISCLOSURE IS CRITICAL
I THINK -- AS A BUYER JADA NOW.
AS A SELLER JADA NOW AS A
HOMEOWNER JADA NOW THAT YOUR
HOUSE ISN'T NECESSARILY FIRE
SAFE AND SO -- WE'RE ALSO
WORKING -- ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN HAS A BILL THAT WILL
HELP IDENTIFY LOW COST RETROFITS --
I WAS LOW COST HIGH VALUE ON THE
OTHER END THERE ARE SIMPLE
THINGS YOU CAN DO TO PROTECT
YOUR HOME BUT IF YOU AS A
HOMEOWNER DON'T KNOW THAT --
YOU'RE NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO
PURSUE THAT AND THE END OF THE
DAY IN THIS IS NOT TRYING TO BE
PUNITIVE THIS ACTUALLY TRYING TO
BE HELPFUL.
BUT CHANGING BEHAVIORS HARD
PEOPLE DON'T ALWAYS WANT TO
CHANGE BEHAVIOR AND I WOULD
IMAGINE WE'RE GOING TO START AN
OUTREACH PROGRAM PROMOTE THE
FACT THAT.
THIS IS AN AFFECT THOSE PEOPLE
WHO ARE REMAINING WHO WOULD LIKE
TO REMAIN IN THEIR HOMES THEY
CAN GO AHEAD AND OBTAIN HOSE
LOANS.
AND EVERYONE OF THOSE AFFECTED
AREAS WOULD BE AWARE OF IT YEAH
I THINK I BELIEVE OUR CAR FIRE
OUR FIRE SAFE COUNCILS ARE
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICTS --
THAT WORK LOCALLY -- TO HELP
PEOPLE -- PROTECT THEMSELVES
FROM FIRE THEY'RE GOING TO BE
ENTHUSIASTIC AMBASSADORS FOR
THIS PROGRAM AND I'M CONFIDENT
THAT THAT THEY WILL GET THE WORD
OUT.
I THINK THE BILL WILL SAVE LIVES
AND PROPERTY THANK YOU.
OKAY ASSEMBLY WE DO NOT HAVE A
QUORUM AS OF YET I JUST DO WANT
TO MAKE A COMMENT FIRST OF ALL I
REALLY LIKE YOUR BILL I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT.
I THINK THIS IS THE NEW NOT
NORMAL TYPE OF THE END OF THE
ROAD THE REAL ESTATE
ORGANIZATIONS ARE GONNA HAVE TO
GET USED -- TO I BECAUSE I I
THINK IT'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
THAT WE START.
PARDEE HOMES ONE OF THE THINGS
AS WE WERE.
WORKING ON HOW QUICKLY YOU
FORGET THE BILL NUMBERS BUT
YESTERDAY AN FIFTY FOUR THANK
YOU THAT ONE FIFTY FOR THAT ONE
YOU'LL BE WORKING ON ON THURSDAY --
YEAH WHEN WE ARE WORKING ON
TRYING TO GET FUNDING AND
ALKING TO THE THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE ABOUT.
HARDENING OF HOMES -- THEY DON'T
REALLY BELIEVE THAT THE
INVESTMENT THERE THERE'S A LOT
OF OTHER INVESTMENTS THAT -- ON
THE PAY OFF MORE AND I REALLY
BELIEVE THIS IS IMPORTANT
PARTICULARLY IN THE WE WE AND
THAT'S WHERE A LOT OF THESE
FIRES HAVE REALLY.
DONE MOST OF THEIR DAMAGE IN
TERMS OF HOME DESTRUCTION.
SO I I I THINK WE'RE GONNA NEED
IT AND AND MAYBE -- MISS
FORSBERG YOU'VE GOT SOME
COMMENTS ON THIS THAT I THINK BY
THE TIME THIS THING LEAVES HERE
AS IT.
GETS THE THE OTHER THREE THROUGH
THIS PLACE INTO THE GOVERNOR
BESIDE YOU'RE GOING TO NEED SOME
INFORMATION THAT WILL HELP US.
OR HELP THEM DETERMINE HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO TO DO THIS
AND WHAT A GOOD INVESTMENT IS TO
HAVE ANY COMMENTS ON THAT.
SURE ABSOLUTELY JUST THE MORE
THAT WE CAN INVEST IN OUR
COMMUNITIES TO MAKE THEM FIRE
ADOPTED IS REALLY CRITICAL.
AND LIKE I SAID IN MY TESTIMONY
WE PROVIDED RESOURCES TO HELP
IMPROVE OUR FOREST NEED HELP TO
PRINT PROVE OUR COMMUNITY CITY
FIRE SCIENCE AND THE MORE THAT
WE CAN DO. TO ENSURE THAT WE SEE
SOME FUNDING FOR THESE
ACTIVITIES THIS YEAR THE BETTER
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS IS WE
GET A QUORUM A VOTE ON YOUR BILL.
THANK YOU MUCH APPRECIATED THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THIS KALRA.
AB.
FIVE SEVEN TWO THAT'S ITEM
NUMBER.
FIVE SHE SAID THAT.
AND FOR THE RECORD LET IT BE
KNOWN THAT THE CONSTRUCTION
EMPLOYERS ASSOCIATION HAS
REMOVED THEIR OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU I THINK IT WAS SURE
MEMBERS -- WITH THE FIRST LIKE
TO ACCEPT SUGGESTED COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AS OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS TO EXEMPT.
CREDIT CARD PURCHASE THE TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS OR LESS
THAN A JUST OPERATED DATES IN
THE BILL.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE SEVENTY TWO
THE CALIFORNIA DEFORESTATION
FREE PROCUREMENT ACT WOULD
REQUIRE STATE PROCUREMENT
CONTRACTS WITH FOREST'S RISK
COMMODITIES LIKE PALM OIL SOY
CATTLE RUBBER APPALLED.
ENTERED OVER NUDE ON OR AFTER
JANUARY FIRST. TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TO CERTIFY THEIR OPERATIONS AND
THEIR SUPPLY CHAINS ARE NOT
CONTRIBUTING TO TROPICAL
DEFORESTATION.
TROPICAL DEFORESTATION
RESPONSIBLE PERSON IF CAN
PORTION OF GLOBAL GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS THAT CAUSE CLIMATE
CHANGE AS WELL AS WIDE RANGING
IMPACT SOMEBODY DIVERSITY AND
HUMAN RIGHTS.
AB FIVE SEVENTY TWO A SEARCH OUR
CALIFORNIA VALUES AND EXTENDS
ENVIRONMENTAL LEADERSHIP TO THE
PROTECTION OF TROPICAL FORESTS
SENDING A POWERFUL SIGNAL TO
GLOBAL MARKETS THAT A LEGAL AND
DESTRUCTIVE COMMODITY GERMAN
DEFORESTATION WILL NO LONGER BE
TOLERATED.
SB FIVE SEVENTY TWO IS NOT
DISSIMILAR TO WAYS TGS CERTIFIES
CONTRACTORS ARE NOT ENGAGING
CERTAIN BEHAVIORS AND THE BILL
IS ACTUALLY MODELED AFTER AN
EXISTING BECAME A BAN AGAINST
CHILD LABOR.
THE STATE HAS HAD IN PRACTICE
FOR MANY YEARS.
JUNE EIGHTEENTH AMENDMENTS WHICH
EXEMPTS PUBLIC WORKS BROOKS
PROJECTS ON THE BILL AND SAID
RESTRICTS THAT STATE -- FROM
PUTTING FOR US WAS WHICH
PROHIBITED UNDER THE LACEY ACT
IN BIT SPECIFICATIONS REMOVED
OPPOSITION FROM THE CONSTRUCTION
EMPLOYERS ASSOCIATION.
THERE'S A REASONABLE EXPECTATION
ON STATE CONTRACTORS IN RETURN
FOR THE BUSINESS THAT THAT THEY
GET. TO TAKE REASONABLE STEPS
BUT THE PRODUCT CARE SOURCING DO
NOT INCLUDE FORREST.
FOREST RISK COMMODITIES ALSO IN
ORDER TO PROMOTE GUIDANCE AND
BEST PRACTICES AB BY SEVENTY TWO
REQUIRES YES DEVELOP A
DEPORTATION FREE CODE OF CONDUCT
THAT INCLUDES A LIST OF FOR US
WAS COMMODITIES.
AND GUIDANCE TO CONTRACTORS IN
ORDER TO IDENTIFY FORCED RISK
COMMODITIES IN THE SUPPLY CHAIN.
WITH ME PROVIDE SUPPORTING
TESTIMONY UP OUR JEFF CONANT UP
ON BEHALF OF FRIENDS OF THE
EARTH AN EXACT ON BEHALF OF SUCH
COMPASSION LEGISLATION AND PEACE
FOR ANIMALS.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE --
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK HERE TODAY CALIFORNIA
PRIDES ITSELF ON BEING A CLIMATE
LEADER A LEADER IN INNOVATION
AND A LEADER IN SUSTAINABLE
BUSINESS.
MY ORGANIZATION FRIENDS OF THE
EARTH WAS FOUNDED IN CALIFORNIA
IN NINETEEN SIXTY NINE AND HAS
BEEN A PROUD PART OF THIS LEGACY
NOW 450- YEARS.
AS MISTER KALRA SAID
DEFORESTATION CAUSES UP 220% OF
GLOBAL GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
AND IS A MAJOR CAUSE OF THE
EXTINCTION CRISIS AS WELL AS A
KEY ELEMENT.
BEHIND ABUSES OF INDIGENOUS
PEOPLES RIGHTS ACROSS THE TOP
TROPICS THESE ARE THE PRIMARY
REASONS WHY WE AT FRIENDS OF THE
EARTH HAVE BEEN BEHIND AB FIVE
SEVENTY TWO FROM DAY.
ONE USING CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMIC
POWER TO FIGHT THE TROPICAL
DEFORESTATION CRISIS JUST MAKES
GOOD ENVIRONMENTAL SENSE.
BUT THE BILL ALSO MAKES GOOD
BUSINESS SENSE.
IN THE PAST FIVE YEARS NEARLY
FIVE HUNDRED GLOBAL COMPANIES
HAVE MADE COMMITMENTS TO
ELIMINATE DEFORESTATION FROM
THEIR SUPPLY CHAINS THIS
INCLUDES COMPANIES THAT WE ALL
RECOGNIZE -- CARGILL UNILEVER
NESTLE PEPSICO -- CRAFT ALL OF
THE MAJOR CONSUMER BRAND
COMPANIES HAVE MADE A COMMITMENT
TO REMOVE DEFORESTATION FROM
THEIR SUPPLY CHAINS BUT MANY OF
THEM ARE HAVING TROUBLE
IMPLEMENTING THESE COMMITMENTS.
AND HUNDREDS MORE COMPANIES HAVE
MADE NO SUCH COMMITMENTS TO MAKE
BEST PRACTICE COMMON PRACTICE WE
NEED TO LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD
SO THAT.
EVERY COMPANY POTENTIALLY LINKED
TO TROPICAL DEFORESTATION FACES
THE SAME MARKET RULES THE SAME
MARKET RISKS AND CAN EXPECT THE
SAME MARKET REWARDS.
AND HAT'S WHAT AB FIVE SEVENTY
TWO WILL DO FOLLOWING SIMILAR
POLICIES IN EUROPE AB FIVE
SEVENTY TWO WILL BE A KEY STEP
IN CREATING A LEGAL LANDSCAPE TO
ENCOURAGE ROGUE COMPANIES. TO
MEET THE SAME STANDARDS AS THE
SUSTAINABILITY LEADERS.
JUST LAST YEAR CALPERS BECAME
THE FIRST PUBLIC PENSION FUND IN
THE COUNTRY TO ADOPT A POLICY
RECOGNIZING DEFORESTATION AS A
MATERIAL RISK TO ITS INVESTMENTS.
AND TODAY WE'VE GOT A LETTER
THAT'S BEEN -- I THINK SHARED
WITH ALL OF YOU -- FROM SOCIALLY
RESPONSIBLE INVESTMENT FIRMS
REPRESENTING FOUR HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS IN ASSETS UNDER
MANAGEMENT URGING YOU TO SUPPORT
AB FIVE SEVENTY TWO AGAIN
BECAUSE IT MAKES GOOD BUSINESS
SENSE.
SO LET'S CONTINUE TO MAKE
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE LEADER A
LEADER IN SUSTAINABLE BUSINESS
ON A GLOBAL INNOVATOR PLEASE
SUPPORT THE CALIFORNIA
DEFORESTATION FREE PARKING AN
ACT.
THANK YOU.
HI CHAIR MY NAME IS NICHOLAS
SACKETT SOCIAL COMPASSION
LEGISLATION ALSO REPRESENTING
PIECE FOR ANIMALS THE OTHER PROD
CO SPONSOR OF THE BILL.
A LAST YEAR I WENT -- TO BORNEO
AND SUMATRA AND SOLVE THE
DEVASTATION.
OF FIRSTHAND THIS TAKING PLACE
TO THOSE TROPICAL FORESTS.
ARE THESE FORCE ARE HOME TO
THOUSANDS OF ENDANGERED PLANT
AND ANIMAL SPECIES INCLUDING THE
ANIMAL -- THAT INDIGENOUS PEOPLE
CALL THEIR RING A TANK OR PERSON
OF THE FOREST.
WE SHARED NEARLY 97% OF THE SAME
DNA WITH A RING AND HANGS.
DURING INTENSE ARE ONE OF THE
MOST CRITICALLY ENDANGERED OF
THE GREAT APES DUE TO HABITAT
LOSS FOR PALM OIL AND WOOD POLE
PLANTATIONS.
THIS IS A CRUCIAL TIME FOR
RANTINGS THE RANKING CONSERVANCY
BELIEVES THERE ONLY ABOUT FIFTY
TO SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND LEFT.
IN THE WILD ALMOST 80% OF BRING
TING HABITAT HAS DISAPPEARED IN
THE LAST TWENTY YEARS DUE TO
DEFORESTATION.
LOCAL CONSERVATIONISTS ARE
BEGGING FOR HELP FROM OUTSIDE
THEIR BORDERS DEMAND FOR PALM
OIL HAS PUSHED NATIONAL LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO TURN A BLIND EYE
TO UNSUSTAINABLE CULTIVATION.
OF THESE COMMODITIES AND
CONSERVATIONISTS BELIEVE IF LEFT
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS EVERY PLANT
AND EVERY ANIMAL WILL BE BURNED
AND KILLED ALL FOR SHORT TERM
GAME.
WITHOUT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBER SCOTT
GOVERNOR ABOUT FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION PLAYERS ASSOCIATION
LIKE TO THINK THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSORS BUT THESE CHANGES TO
REMOVE OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THREE SEPARATE ON BEHALF THE
SERIES JUST ONE ECHO THE
IMPORTANCE FOR SUSTAINABLE
BUSINESS PRACTICES.
THANK YOU SCOTT FOR THE RECORD
ANY OPPOSITION SEEING NONE
TURNED BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
HERE ANYBODY HAVE ANY COMMENTS
QUESTIONS NO.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GOOD BILL WE WILL --
VOTE ON THIS AS SOON AS WE GET A
QUORUM THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
YEAH BUT I DON'T KNOW WE GOTTA
DO IS HERE MISTER DOLLAR.
MR GARCIA'S BEEN PATIENTLY
WAITING BUT THERE'S ALWAYS
SOMEBODY THAT COMES IN. TWENTY
SEVEN MORNING EDITOR SENATORS --
TODAY PRESENTING AB EIGHT FORTY
RELATED TO THE CAL NEVA RESORT
AND CASINO IN LAKE TAHOE.
AREA OF KING BEACH CALIFORNIA
AND THE DISTRICT.
AND CRYSTAL BAY OF NEVADA.
THIS RESORT STRADDLES THE
CALIFORNIA NEVADA BORDER WHICH
MAKES IT VERY UNIQUE.
THIS BILL SIMPLY SEEKS TO CREATE
A NARAL LICENSE TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE OF ALCOHOL USE.
WITHIN RESORTS AS PART OF THE
RESORT IS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND PART OF HIS IN NEVADA I WORK
CLOSELY WITH A ALCOHOL BEVERAGE
CONTROL TO ENSURE WE HAVE THE
MOST ACCURATE LANGUAGE I HAVE
KELLY JENSEN HERE IS
REPRESENTING SEEN IN HOTEL
HOLDINGS. TO TESTIFY BEHALF THIS
BILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
CENTER.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS KELLY JENSEN
REPRESENTING SEEIN.
HOTEL HOLDINGS -- AS THE AUTHOR
INDICATED WE WORK VERY HARD WITH
THE A. B. C. TO CRAFT -- THE
BILL TO FIT THE UNIQUE -- IN AN
HISTORIC NATURE OF THE FACILITY.
WE BELIEVE WE FOUND THAT -- IN
THE RECENT AMENDMENTS APPRECIATE
THE COMMITTEE'S COMMENTS ON THE
BILL AND WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION --
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE SEEING
NONE OF THE YOU KNOW I REALLY
APPRECIATE THIS BILL BECAUSE THE
OF THE LAST THING YOU WANT IS A
BUSINESS TAP INTO.
IT WILL.
DEAL WITH MULTI JR JURISDICTIONS
TO DIFFERENT STATES TO DIFFERENT
LAWS I THINK IT'S A GOOD
COMMONSENSE BILL ON APPRECIATE
BRING IT FORWARD.
AND WILL BE VOTING ON THIS AS
SOON AS WE GET A QUORUM THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THIS GARCIA LAST.
MORNING ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
AB SIX FORTY NINE PERMITS A
PERSON WHO IS BETWEEN THE AGES
OF EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY YEARS OF
AGE TO OBTAIN A WORK PERMIT IN
ORDER TO BE EMPLOYED IN THE
GAMBLING ESTABLISHMENT.
AS LONG AS THEY DO NOT WORK AYE
STEELERS FOR PERSONNEL OR ANY
OTHER EMPLOYMENT CLASSIFICATION.
THAT INVOLVES WORKING ON THE
FLOOR AND OTHER WORDS BACK OF
THE HOUSE STAFF POSITIONS.
WHILE THE ECONOMY HAS IMPROVED
THE CITY OF COMMERCE WHICH HAS A
CAR CLUB.
OUR UNEMPLOYMENT RATE IS STILL
AT ABOUT 7% IN THE PARTY LEVEL
IS AT ABOUT 17%.
THERE ARE MANY CALIFORNIANS IN
THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY
YEARS A RANGE THAT ARE CURRENTLY
LOOKING FOR WORK OPPORTUNITIES.
IN CALIFORNIA THAT INCLUDES
VETERANS SINGLE PARENTS SOME
COLLEGE STUDENTS THAT NEED TO
WORK WHILE THEY COMPLETE THEIR
EDUCATION.
THIS BILL HELPS CREATE AN
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU WITNESSES SPORT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TOMISLAV
PREFER COMMERCE CALIFORNIA
COMMERCE CASINO AND HOTEL -- WE
SUPPORT THE BILL WE'VE ARE OFTEN
WONDERED WHY WE CAN'T EVER
VALETS AND IN A NUMBER OF OUR
EMPLOYEES -- ABLE -- TO BE OF AN
AGE THAT THEY GIVE THEM A START --
WE'RE WE'RE PROUD IN OUR CASINO
THAT WE HAVE AND HOTEL THAT WE
HAVE FOLKS WHO HAVE BEEN WITH US.
FOR TWENTY FIVE AND THIRTY YEARS
SINCE AND WE'RE HOPING THAT SOME
OF THESE YOUNG FOLKS.
CAN START WITH US IN AND TURN IT
INTO A CAREER -- THEY'RE GONNA
BE AIDID AND THEY'RE NOT GONNA
BE DOING ANYTHING TO DO WITH
CAME IN BUT TO DO WITH -- FOOD
SERVICE HI IN ANOTHER SERVICES
WITH US FOR MEDICAL.
EXPERTS LIBERTY X. WITH THIS.
ROSS REGARD FOR CHRIS SIX
CRYSTAL CASINO AND OCEANS ELEVEN
IS STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
WITNESSES OPPOSITION SEEING NONE
CENTER ARE TO LET UP YES --
THANK YOU SO REMEMBER THIS IS A
GREAT BUILT IN MY DISTRICT I'D
BE HONORED TO BE A CO AUTHOR ON
THIS WITH YOU.
I THINK THIS IS WELL OVERDUE I
KNOW THE THE OWNERS OF THE
CASINO OF WHAT A PROFESSIONAL
OPERATION THEY HAVE.
AND I KNOW THAT -- GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TEACH YOUNG
PEOPLE TO GROW INTO THE
KNOWLEDGE OF THE HOTEL BUSINESS
CASINO BUSINESS JUST BUSINESS IN
GENERAL.
WILL OPEN UP THE DOORS
ESPECIALLY FOR THE COMMUNITY
THAT IS AND TO CASINOS IN MY
DISTRICT AND IN THIS IS IN --
YOU HAVE ONE IN YOUR DISTRICT AS
WELL SO I THINK THIS IS GREAT
AND I APPRECIATE YOU BRING IN
FORT.
THANK YOU HAVE MY SUPPORT WHAT
THEY'RE THINKING THANK YOU.
I TO APPRECIATE THAT THIS BILL
WILL VOTE ON THAT IS SOON AS WE
GET A QUORUM THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MR SALAS THIS WILL BE ITEM
NUMBER SIX AB.
FIVE NINE FOUR MORNING MR
WARNING COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PRESENT FOR YOUR SIMPLY BILL.
FIVE NINETY FOUR TERRIFIC.
THE AIM OF THIS BILLS TACKLE TWO
MAIN ISSUES ASSOCIATED WITH
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE -- TO
PROVIDE OVERSIGHT AND EXPERTISE
IN THE USE OF A AYE IN STATE
GOVERNMENT.
AND TO ADDRESS POTENTIAL IMPACTS
FOR WORK FOR SPECIFICALLY THIS
BILL WOULD ESTABLISH A CHIEF
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE OFFICER
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY TO EVALUATE THE USES
OF ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE.
AND STATE GOVERNMENT AND TO
ADVISE THE DIRECTOR OF
TECHNOLOGY ON INCORPORATING
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE IN THE
STATE INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
PLANS AND POLICIES.
THE CHIEF ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE OFFICER WOULD IN
ADDITION ADVISED CLIFORNIA
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD IN
ITS REVIEW OF WORKFORCE
EDUCATION AND TRAINING TO
PREPARE AND TRAIN WORKERS
POTENTIALLY DISPLACED BY A AYE.
WE SEE AN INCREASING NUMBER OF A
AYE BEING -- NOT ONLY DEVELOP IT
ALSO UTILIZE OUR CITIES THAT ARE
NOW STARTING TO UTILIZE A I
ACTUALLY -- FOR INSTANCE IN THE
COURTS TO PREVENT RACIAL BIAS
FOR INSTANCE SO AS WE CONTINUE
TO MOVE THIS WE THINK WE SHOULD
BE MOVING IN THIS DIRECTION AND
WE DO HAVE I DO HAVE -- MISTER
NOW HERE -- IT SUPPORT. TO TEST
THE MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
AND SENATORS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO TESTIFY MY NAME
IS PEDRO NOMINAL FORMER MEMBER
OF THE ASSEMBLY AND CURRENTLY
SERVICES CHAIR OF THE LITTLE
HOOVER COMMISSION.
BUT OVER COMMISSION STUDY THE
AREA OF A AYE SOMETIME AGO A
NUMEROUS WITNESSES THREE
DIFFERENT HEARINGS -- REVIEW OF
THE LITERATURE AND STUDIES AND
WE CAME TO THE CONCLUSION THAT
UNFORTUNATELY.
CALIFORNIA'S FALLING BEHIND MANY
OTHER STATES.
IN OTHER COUNTRIES WITH RESPECT
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE -- OTHER
STATES SUCH AS INDIANA AS AN
EXAMPLE HAVE ALREADY ESTABLISH
COMMISSIONS THAT ARE DOING SOME
OF THE THINGS THAT WE
RECOMMENDED WE SUPPORT THIS
LEGISLATION.
BECAUSE IT FOLLOWS ONE OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE HAD IN
OUR REPORT AND THAT WS FOR
SOMEONE.
IN A HIGH LEVEL POSITION TO
OCCUPY THE SPOT OF THE
INTELLIGENCE ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE OFFICER AND THIS
LEGISLATION DOES THAT -- IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR CALIFORNIA TO
INSURE THAT WE DON'T LOSE.
OUR LEADERSHIP POSITION
PARTICULARLY ON ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE AS WE MOVE FORWARD --
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT OF THE BILL --
WITH THE AUTHOR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
CENTER ON JULY WOULD YOU LIKE%
YES THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD -- DUE TO BE A THEY HAVE
THE THE TECHNOLOGY OBVIOUSLY THE
ROBOTICS THAT WE'RE LOOKING INTO
NOW.
BECAUSE WE'VE GOT THE PORT OF
LONG BEACH SAN PEDRO ALL THE
OTHER PORTION OF COURSE.
THERE THE LONGSHOREMEN ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE THE
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE AND
ROBOTICS THAT ARE THERE IN THE
FUTURE.
AND I NOTICED THAT THE THAT THE
THE COMMISSION IN THIS CASE
WOULD BE LOOKING AT THE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT.
AND EDUCATION AND TRAINING -- TO
MAKE SURE THAT EMPLOYMENT IS A
DAMAGE -- WITH THE FUTURE WITH
INTELLIGENCE SHORT SEEMS LIKE
WILL BE ABLE TO GET EVALUATION
HOW THAT'S COMING TOGETHER.
BECAUSE IT WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
THE FUTURE WE OBVIOUSLY HAVE TO
INCLUDE THE THE EMPLOYEES --
THEIR FAMILIES AND EVERYONE ELSE
SO THEY CAN FEEL SECURE THAT THE
JOBS WILL NOT BE LOSS BECAUSE OF
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE.
BUT MARSHALL IN THE FUTURE
THEY'LL BE INCOMPETENCE.
AS ONE THROUGH EDUCATION AND I
THINK THIS IS OUR FIRST STEP TO
GIVE A SENSE OF CALM. TO WHAT --
THEY'RE CONCERNED ABOUT THAT
THEY WILL BE INVOLVED THEY'LL
HAVE A VOICE HAVE -- AN
OPPORTUNITY TO EDUCATE
THEMSELVES AND SO WE CAN
PROGRESS ALONG AND TAKE A RIDE
FIREMAN AS WELL.
SO THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER -- WHICH IS WE
HAVE A QUORUM A VOTE ON THIS I
BELIEVE YOU HAVE A SECOND ONE UP
RIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MEMBERS --
THAT'S THE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN AB
NINE SEVEN WHAT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
I'M PLEASE PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
NINE SEVENTY ONE OF THIS BILL
WILL INCREASE ACCOUNTABILITY
BETWEEN THE STATE IN NINETY
CONTRACTORS BY REQUIRING
DEPARTMENTS TO CONDUCT.
A POST EVALUATION AFTER NINETY
PROJECT IS COMPLETED CURRENTLY
FIRST EVALUATIONS ARE ONLY
REQUIRED FOR MINOR CONSULTING
SERVICES NOT LARGER PROJECTS.
AB MEMBERS WE DON'T HAVE TO GO
VERY FAR TO ACTUALLY SEE IN THE
HEADLINES IT PROJECTS AGO -- BUT
DELAYED AND OVER COSTS THIS
MEASURE YEARS DESIGNED ACTUALLY
HELP WITH SOME OF THAT AND
ACTUALLY PROVIDE OPPOSED
EVALUATION WITH THAT AT THE TIME
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES OPPOSITION ANY MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE WISHING -- TO
COMMENT SEEING NONE I THINK
THERE'S A GREAT BILL WILL VOTE
ON IT AS SOON AS WE HAVE A
QUORUM THANK YOU SOME AMERICA
MISTER THANK YOU MEMBERS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER IRWIN AND WE HAVE
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB.
TWO FORTY GOOD MORNING.
SHARE DODD AND MEMBERS OF FIRST
I GRATEFULLY ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS THE
VETERAN HOMES ARE LOCATED ALL
OVER CALIFORNIA BUT THE CROWN
JEWEL OF THE SYSTEM IS THE
OROVILLE HOME.
AND THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS ROOM
WHO KNOWS MORE ABOUT THE HOME
THEN THE CHAIR AND I'M GRATEFUL
FOR HIS -- SUGGESTIONS IN THE
WORK OF HIS COMMITTEES THE STAFF
THIS BILL IMPLEMENT SOME OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR BETTER
MANAGING NON STATE USES A
VETERNS HOME PROPERTY.
THIS BILL WOULD STRENGTHEN AND
CLARIFYING EXIST AND CLARIFY
EXISTING LAW AROUND THESE TERMS.
RECOGNIZING THE WAY THAT THE YON
PHIL HOME IN PARTICULAR IS A
SIGNIFICANT COMMUNITY MEMBERS
WHOSE USES HAVE EVOLVED
ORGANICALLY OVER HUNDREDS OF
YEARS.
THIS BILL ALSO PROVIDES A
FRAMEWORK FOR LEGALLY GRANTING
LONGER TERM LEASES PROVIDED --
LEGISLATIVE APPROVAL.
THE BILL ALSO STRENGTHENS
EXISTING STANDARDS BY REQUIRING
THAT EIGHT USE PROVIDE A
SUBSTANTIAL AND DIRECT.
BENEFIT TO THE HOMES AND IT'S
MEMBERS AND DOES NOT SUBVERT THE
HOMES PURPOSE WE'VE BEEN WORKING
HARD TO STRIKE THE RIGHT BALANCE
BETWEEN GRANTING FLEXIBILITY
UNDER THE LAW THAT IT KNOWLEDGE
AS LONG STANDING ARRANGEMENTS
AND CREATING A RIGOROUS STANDARD
THAT INSURERS THESE HOMES ARE
OPERATED PRINCIPALLY FOR THE
BENEFIT.
OF CALIFORNIA VETERANS.
YOU VERY MUCH.
ME WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
YOUR DAUGHTER MEMBERS ALEX
TOWARDS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
VETERANS SERVICE AGENCIES IN
VERY STRONG SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
IN THE MEMBERS CENTRE ARTILLERY
YEAH.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AS YOU
KNOW I'M THE CHAIR OF THE
VETERANS COMMITTEE.
AND THE VETERANS HOMES ARE
SACRED GROUND.
THEIR SACRED TO OUR VETERANS AND
I'M AND THIS -- ACKNOWLEDGES THE
FACT THAT THE AUDIT SHOWED THAT
THERE WERE SOME IMPROPRIETIES
BUTWITH THIS BILL LEVELS THAT
OFF -- THOSE WHO ARE WORKING
WITH OUR VETERANS ARE ABLE TO
OBTAIN THEIR LEASES FIVE YEAR
INTERVALS AND IF THERE'S
SOMETHING THAT POTENTIAL
LONGLEY'S IT'LL COME BEFORE THE
LEGISLATION PROCESS AND I
APPRECIATE THAT.
SO I THINK THIS -- ADDRESSES THE
CONCERNS THAT ARE BETTER CHAD
AND AT THE SAME TIME IS WORKING
WITH THE COMMUNITIES AS WELL AND
I THINK YOU BRING IN A FORD.
HAS MY SUPPORT.
YEAH I APPRECIATE YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO WORK -- I THINK
JUST FOR THE RECORD IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT I THINK
THAT.
IS CERTAINLY THIS WAS THE
AUDITOR THEY CAME UP WITH THESE
AND I DON'T THINK AS A RESULT OF
ANY COMPLAINTS FROM THE VETERANS.
AND YOU KNOW ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I WORRIED ABOUT IS ALL THE
SAME AS RESULT OF THIS AUDIT --
AND THE SUBSEQUENT -- YEAH
POTENTIAL LEGISLATION I THINK
THE ID CCTV HAS TAKEN OR THEIR
MANAGEMENT AT THE HOME IS TAKEN
AT ANTI COMMUNITY.
TYPE OF APPROACH -- TO THE CITY
OF THEIR TOWN OF YACHT BILL AND
THE COUNTY OF NAPA WHICH IS
CAUSING A GREAT DEAL OF
CONSTERNATION WE'VE GOT TO
REMEMBER THESE HOMES ARE PART OF
EVERY COMMUNITY.
AND WALLOWING IT OFF BY EXIT BY
REGULATION AND THE NOT SAYING
THAT THIS DOES NOT DO IT.
BUT I BUT WHAT I DIDN'T WANT TO
DO IS I DID NOT WANT TO GIVE THE
CD BE.
THE I DON'T KNOW THE AUTHORITY
TO JUST COMPLETELY WALL OFF A
COMMUNITY THESE VETERANS ARE
PART OF THE COMMUNITIES IN WHICH
THEY LIVE AT SO I REALLY.
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR WORK IN --
WITH ME TO MAKE SURE THAT -- WE
DID EXACTLY THAT.
SO WITH THAT -- VERY SUPPORT OF
THE BILL WILL VOTE ON THIS AS
SOON AS WE GET A QUORUM THANK
YOU SAM A MEMBER.
NEXT UP ASSEMBLY CUNNINGHAM
THERE YOUR THAT'S ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN AB [inaudible]
THIRTEEN OH EIGHT ALWAYS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
SENATORS.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB THIRTEEN
OH EIGHT WHICH SEEKS TO CLARIFY
THE LAW TO ALLOW QUALIFIED
STUDENTS TO TASTE ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES.
TASTE NOT CONSUME IF THEY ARE
TAKING A DEGREE PROGRAM FROM A
COLLEGE IN HOTEL MANAGEMENT OR
CULINARY ARTS.
IN NINETEEN NINE THE LEGISLATURE.
BUT EXCUSE ME IN IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN THE LEGISLATURE PASSED
A BE.
NINETEEN NINE THAT'LL ARE
QUALIFIED STUDENTS THE ABILITY
TO TASTE ALCOHOL EVEN IF THEY
ARE.
TWENTY ONE IF THEY'RE IN CERTAIN
DEGREE PROGRAMS BUT THE COLLEGES
HAVE BEEN RELUCTANT OR HESITANT.
TO ALLOW THAT BECAUSE OF A
SEMANTIC UNIT IN THE LOT FOR
FEAR OF LIABILITY -- THIS BILL
SEEKS TO CLARIFY THAT LAW AND
AGAIN ONLY IF THE STUDENTS ARE
INVOLVED IN.
THE SPECIFIC DEGREE PROGRAMS OF
HOTEL MANAGEMENT AND CULINARY
ARTS AND I'D SAY THIS IS
SOMETHING OF A DISTRICT BILL CAL
POLY SINCE OBISPO.
QUEST TO COLLEGE HANCOCK COLLEGE
AND TO A LESSER DEGREE ALTHOUGH
IT'S NOT QUITE MY DISTRICT BUT
SANTA BARBARA CITY COLLEGE ALL
HAVE THESE PROGRAMS.
OTHER VERY POPULAR THERE A LOT
OF STUDENTS AND ROLLED AND
TOURISM IS A BIG DRIVER OUR
ECONOMY SO.
WE'RE HOPING TO CLARIFY THE LAW
AND AND LET THE STUDENTS TASTE
AND AGAIN NOT CONSUME BUT JUST
TASTE THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
WITNESSES SUPPORT [inaudible]
WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
TURN BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANYBODY HAVE ANY COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE SOME EVER WE DO NOT
HAVE A QUORUM WE'RE WORKING ON
THAT AS WE SPEAK.
I WILL VOTE ON YOUR BILL AS SOON
AS WE HAVE A QUORUM THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU JACK TO
CLOSE I JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR ABOUT THANK YOU.
THE THIRD TIME IN A WE NEED
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS FRIEDMAN OR
JONES SAWYER
[inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible]
ALL [inaudible]
THE KIND [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
THE YEAH.
ALL RIGHT RESERVED SEATING ROOM
OKAY [inaudible]
YEAH.
BUT WHAT OUR OWN.
I I'M SORRY [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
THIS [inaudible] FIVE HELLO.
HELLO.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN WE HAVE
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN A. B. A
LOVE AND A LOT OF IT
[inaudible]
AMENDMENTS.
TO HELLO MISTER CHAIR.
MEMBERS VERY NICE TO SEE YOU ALL --
FIRST OF ALL EXCEPT THE
SUGGESTED COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON
PAGE FOUR OF THE ANALYSIS ADDING
A FIVE YEAR SUNSET TO THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE OFFICE.
AB ELEVEN ELEVEN CREATES NEW OUT
OFFICE OF OUTDOOR RECREATION FOR
CALIFORNIA WITHIN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE.
AB ELEVEN ELEVEN RECOGNIZES THAT
THE OUTDOOR RECREATION ECONOMY
IS TREMENDOUS IN OUR STATE.
OVER NINETY TWO BILLION DOLLARS
COMES INTO OUR ECONOMY BECAUSE
OF OUTDOOR RECREATION SPENDING.
AND ECONOMIC ACTIVITY AT A
DIRECTLY CREATES MORE THAN SIX
HUNDRED AND NINETY THOUSAND JOBS.
A NEW OFFICE ABOUT A RECREATION
WILL HELP CREATE NEW ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CALIFORNIA.
AND HARNESS THE CREATIVITY AND
INNOVATION.
IN THE FIELD IT WILL COLLABORATE
WITH OTHER GOVERNMENTAL PROGRAMS
AND SERVICES AND PROMOTE
BUSINESS RELATED PROGRAMS TO THE
OUTDOOR RECREATION INDUSTRY.
PROGRAMS LIKE THE CALIFORNIA
COMPETES TAX CREDIT PROGRAM OR
THE NEW EMPLOYMENT CREDIT
PROGRAM IN ORDER TO RETAIN AND
GROW OUR OUTDOOR RECREATION
BUSINESS.
AND OFFICE ABOUT A RECREATIONAL
A BROADER THAN ONE TYPE OF LAND
MANAGER.
IT WILL FOSTER STATEWIDE
DISCUSSION OF WHAT OUR
PRIORITIES IN PLAN SHOULD BE FOR
SUPPORTING AND GROWING.
THE MULTI BILLION DOLLAR OUTDOOR
RECREATION.
ECONOMY IN CALIFORNIA. FOURTEEN
OTHER STATES HAVE SIMILAR
OFFICES AND EXECUTIVE LEVEL
POSITIONS FOCUSED ON THEIR
STATE'S OUTDOOR RECREATION
SECTORS.
IN THE LAST TWO WEEKS WISCONSIN
ESTABLISHED ONE NOW I'VE HAD
PEOPLE IN MY DISTRICT SAY WHY DO
WE NEED SOMETHING LIKE THIS WE
GOT PEOPLE ALL OVER GROUP WITH
PARK EVERY DAY.
AND THAT'S TRUE BUT THE SAME
PEOPLE DON'T KNOW THAT RIGHT
NEXT DOOR AND SAN GABRIELTHEY
CAN GO ON HOW TO A WATERFALL.
PEOPLE DON'T KNOW THAT THEY CAN
GO UP TO WHITE WATER RAFT IN
PARTS OF THE STATE THAT ARE
DESPERATELY IN NEED OF TOURISM
IN TAURUS DOLLARS.
I'VE HAD MEMBERS FROM RURAL
COUNTIES -- IN THE ASSEMBLY TELL
ME THAT THIS WOULD HELP BRING
THOSE TOURISTS TO COME FROM OUT
OF STATE WHO MAYBE HAVE HEARD OF
YELLOWSTONE BUT I'VE NEVER HEARD
OF THE STANISLAUS.
INTO THEIR AREAS.
THE OTHER THING IS WE HAVE A LOT
OF GOALS ABOUT GETTING
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY MEMBERS
OUT INTO THE OUTDOORS BUT WE
HAVE NO REAL INTER AGENCY
COORDINATION.
OF HOW TO DO THAT AND HOW TO
WORK WITH OUR PRIVATE BUSINESS
SECTORS IN ORDER TO FOSTER THAT
KIND OF COOPERATION TO HELP
BUILD.
THE LOVE OF THE OUTDOORS FOR
PEOPLE LIVING IN THE INNER CITY.
AND TO BRING THEM INTO PARTS OF
THE STATE THAT ARE LESS
ACCESSIBLE.
WITH ME TODAY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN SEVEN
ELEVEN IS SCOTT EMMONS FROM ARI
I AND AND SOMEBODY ELSE.
THE SETTLEMENT IN THERE DONE
THAT.
PLEASE FIRST WITNESS.
HI GOOD MORNING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M SCOTT AMMONS I'M
THE ARI I OUTDOOR PROGRAMS
MANAGER FOR OUR AREA IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WHICH MEANS I RUN OUR
LOCAL GUIDE SERVICE -- I ALSO DO
COMMUNITY PROGRAMS AND RUN OUR
GIVING PROGRAMS AND ARE A
STRONGLY SUPPORTS AB.
ELEVEN ELEVEN SORRY IT HAS.
BEEN A CALIFORNIA BASED BUSINESS
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE WE HAVE
TWENTY EIGHT STORES TWO THOUSAND
EMPLOYEES AND ALMOST FOUR
MILLION CALIFORNIA'S AS MEMBERS
OF OUR COOP.
SO ARE AS A COOPERATIVE THAT IS
MANAGED FOR THE BENEFIT OF HIS
COMMUNITY.ONE THING MOST PEOPLE
DON'T KNOW IS WE GIVE OVER 70%
OF OUR PROFITS BACK. TO THE
COMMUNITY IN THE FORM OF GRANTS
TO LOCAL NGOS MEMBERS AND STAFF --
RECENTLY WE'VE GIVEN ALMOST A
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR TO DOZENS
OF NON PROFITS IN THE STATE.
RANGES FROM THINGS LIKE FRIENDS
OF THE LA RIVER AND TO RESURGENT.
SET UP INTO THE HEALTH BENEFITS
OF TIME OUTDOORS.
SO -- AS SHE WAS SAYING CALPERS
UNDER RECREATION ECONOMY IS ONE
OF THE LARGEST IN THE COUNTRY
AND SUPPORTS ALMOST SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND JOBS.
AND THIS OFFICE ABOUT THE
RECREATION WILL BE ABLE TO
HOLISTICALLY WORK AND GROWING
THE ENTIRE RECREATION SECTOR BY
INCREASING PARTICIPATION.
ADVOCATING FOR INVESTMENT AND
REMOVING BARRIERS TO ACCESS --
IT WOULD IMPROVE THE HEALTH AND
WELL BEING OF EVERYONE IN EVERY
COMMUNITY IN THE STATE.
SO KIDS NOWADAYS SPEND ALMOST
SEVEN HOURS A DAY LOOKING AT
SCREENS AND ADULTS IT'S EVEN
WORSE IT'S ELEVEN HOURS A DAY --
MEANWHILE HEALTHCARE COSTS ARE
GOING UP.
SO PROMOTING OUTDOOR RECREATION
IS SOMETHING THAT'S GOOD FOR OUR
ECONOMY BUT IT'S ALSO GOOD FOR
THE HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
HI IT WOULD ALSO HELP PROMOTE
BUSINESS IN RECREATION
OPPORTUNITIES AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES.
THIS OFFICE WOULD HELP THE
AGENCIES.
THEY CARE ABOUT THE OUTDOORS
WORK BETTER TOGETHER FROM HEALTH
CARE AGENCIES TO EDUCATION TO
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT TOURISM
AND ENVIRONMENTAL FAIRS.
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THE VALUE OF
TOWN DOORS LIKE THE FOURTEEN
OTHER STATE SET UP OFFICES HE
WOULD MAKE SURE THESE AGENCIES
ARE COORDINATED IN GETTING THE
MAXIMUM SOCIAL.
AND ECONOMIC BENEFITS THANK YOU
FOR SUPPORTING AB ELEVEN ELEVEN
AND THINGS TO ASSEMBLY ONE
FRIEDMAN FOR LEADING IT.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING HI MY
NAME IS MADELINE I IN THE CHAIR
OF THE CALIFORNIA OUTDOOR
RECREATION PARTNERSHIP -- WE
REPRESENT MEMBERS IN THE STATES
THAT ARE OUTDOOR RECREATION GEAR
MANUFACTURES -- IS IT ON THE
REST ARE SORRY I'LL START AGAIN
MY NAME'S MATT LION -- CAIRMAN
OF THE CALIFORNIA TO RECREATION
PARTNERSHIP -- WE REPRESENT A
MEMBERS IN THE STATES THAT ARE
OUT TO RECREATION GEAR
MANUFACTURES SPECIALTY RETAILERS.
AND REGIONAL ECONOMIC AREAS THAT
BENEFIT FROM THE ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY OF OUTDOOR RECREATION --
I'M ALSO THE FOUNDER AND
CHAIRMAN OF HIGH TO PACK A GEAR
MANUFACTURER BASED IN OAKLAND --
EMPLOYING TWENTY FIVE PEOPLE IN
THE AREA AND DISTRIBUTING
PRODUCTS THROUGHOUT THE U. S. --
WE'VE BEEN WORKING FOR SEVERAL
YEARS ON THIS BILL -- AND
EXPLOITATIVE WELL WE REALLY
APPRECIATE ITS ABILITY TO BRING
FORWARD IN A SINGULAR POINT --
THEY OUT TO RECREATION SPACE
WHICH ENCOMPASSES MANY DIFFERENT
THINGS -- BOTH -- CAPITAL ASSETS
PARTICIPATION IN OUTDOOR
RECREATION -- AND EMPLOYMENT IN
RURAL AREAS -- SO WE STRONGLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT IN FAVOR
THIS BILL.
THIS IS IN SUPPORT.
MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BRING GARCIA ON BEHALF
OF THE FRONT OF THE LA RIVER THE
COMMITTEE NATURE CONNECTION LOS
ANGELES A WITH A TRANSFER AS
NATURE FOR ALL.
CONSIDERED RELEASED IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING KATIE HAWKINS FROM
THE OUTDOOR ALLIANCE IN FULL
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MARK
FENCER MAKER FOR THE SANTA CLARA
VALLEY OPEN SPACE THIRTY IN
SUPPORT.
MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS TH	C
HOUSTON REPRESENT EAST BAY
REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT -- COUNTY
OF CINEMA REGIONAL PARKS AND
WATERSHED CONSERVATION SUPPORT
AT THE READY ON SUPPORT.
SURE MEMBERS JERRY DOES MEN OF
HAVE A RECREATIONAL BOATERS A
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF THE
OBJECTIVES TO PROMOTE OUTDOOR
RECREATION OUR SUPPORT IS A
SOMEWHAT CONDITIONAL.
OF FIRST IS THAT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT IF YOU DEVELOP A OF
FUNDING SOURCES FOR THIS THAT
IT'S NOT AT THE REDIRECTION OF
EXISTING.
OF REVENUES PAID BY VOTERS INTO
DIVISION VOTING -- WATERWAYS AND
OTHER PROGRAMS AND WE LIKE TO
FILL IN SOME IN SUPPORT ALSO
ENCOURAGE A NAMING THE DIVISION
OF BOATING AND WATERWAYS AS AN
ADVISER COMMITTEE MEMBER AS IT
WAS FOR SO THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MARK SMITH
ON BEHALF OF TWO COALITIONS
TODAY MY COMMENTS ARE ACTUALLY
Là MORE EXTENSIVE SHOT COME UP
AND SIT OR IS IT OKAY TO DO IN
HERE.
AT YOUR PLEASURE.
OF THE CURRENT WELL.
SO WOULD LIKE TO START BY CLEAR
FINE -- THAT THE TWO COALITIONS
I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF BOTH
SUPPORT TE BILL -- AND ARE
PLEASED TO SEE THIS MOVING
FORWARD -- BUT WOULD LIKE TO ASK
FOR SOME SPECIFIC AMENDMENTS --
IN PARTICULAR WE HAVE NOTED THAT
THE BILL PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT
THROUGH AN ADVISORY PANEL WITH
THE OFFICE.
BUT THE BILL'S ALSO QUITE
PRESCRIPTIVE IN TERMS OF THE
STATE AGENCY PARTICIPATION THAT
IT REQUIRES INCLUDING EDUCATION --
CITY OF W. AND PARKS WE WOULD
LIKE TO ASK FOR THE INCLUSION OF
TWO ADDITIONAL STATE ENTITIES
AND WE FEEL LIKE IT'S IMPORTANT
TO NAME THOSE IN THE BILL -- AND
WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE BROADER
STAKEHOLDER COMMUNITY HAS ITS
OPPORTUNITIES TO GAUGE AS WELL
FIRST IS THE CALIFORNIA FISH AND
GAME COMMISSION.
AS YOU ARE PROBABLY AWARE
HUNTING IN ANGLING IS A HUGE
FORM OF OUTDOOR RECREATION IN
THE STATE GENERATES.
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO THE
ECONOMY EVERY YEAR AND IS A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF FUNDING
REVENUE TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE.
THE FISH AND GAME COMMISSION IS
A GUBERNATORIAL HE APPOINTED
COMMISSION THAT IS DISTINCT FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE AND HAS SOLE
JURISDICTION.
OVER SETTING REGULATIONS SEASONS
LIMITS EVERYTHING AS IT PERTAINS
TO HUNTING AND FISHING AND SO WE
THINK THAT THEIR PARTICIPATION
IS IMPORTANT.
SECOND -- WE'D LIKE TO ASK FOR
THE INCLUSION OF THE DIVISION OF
BOATING AND WATERWAYS MANY OF
YOU ARE AWARE THAT UNTIL
RECENTLY THIS WAS A STANDALONE
DEPARTMENT.
IT HAS BEEN ROLLED UNDERNEATH
PARKS BUT IT STILL HAS A
SIGNIFICANT PORTFOLIO OF
RESPONSIBILITY INCLUDING SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT ARE TALKED ABOUT.
IN THE FINDINGS OF THE BILL LIKE
BEACH EROSION AND VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT AND WATER WAYS.
OUTDOOR RECREATION ON
CALIFORNIA'S WATER WAYS IS A BIG
COMPONENT OF OUTDOOR RECREATION
WE ARE SECOND ONLY TO FLORIDA.
IN THE NUMBER OF BOATS THAT ARE
LICENSED IN THE FIFTY STATES AND
WE THINK THAT BECAUSE OF THE
RESPONSIBILITIES OF PARKS IT'S
HUGE BREATH -- HAVING ONE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM PARKS IN
GENERAL IS NOT ENOUGH AND THAT
WE WOULD SPECIFICALLY REQUESTED
A PERSON REPRESENTATIVE FROM
DIVISION OF BOATING AND
WATERWAYS BE INCLUDED AS WELL --
AGAIN WE WE DO SUPPORT IN
CONCEPT BUT WE WOULD REALLY LIKE
AN AMENDMENT TO SEE THOSE TWO
STATE ENTITIES ADDED. TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE OFFICE ABOUT
TO RECREATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY BODY ELSE -- IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING THAT ANY COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE COMMITTEE.
WELL HAVING GONE HOPELESSLY FLY
FISHING LAST YEAR WITH THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS AND PLANNING TO
DO IT AGAIN.
IN A MONTH I SEE THE WISDOM OF
WHAT THEY'RE SAYING AND IF THE
CHAIR IS SUPPORTIVE OF THAT I'M
CERTAINLY FIND WITH.
ADDING THAT.
ADDING SPECIFICALLY THE FISSION
GAME -- MEMBER AND MAKING SURE
THAT THE STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDE
ALL OF THE MAJOR STAKEHOLDERS
INCLUDING THE VOTING --
REPRESENTATIVE BUT IT'S UP TO
THE CHAIR.
IF YOU'RE FOR THAT IT TAKES WAY
ALL OPPOSITION ANY OBJECTION.
OUR WITH THE WITH FISHING GAMES
ARE WILL DO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND GAME WE DON'T HAVE ANY --
DIFFERENT SORT OF WE DON'T SAY
THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE AN A
QUESTION REPRESENTATIVE FOR A
BOAT REPRESENTATIVE THAT'S KIND
OF TO BE DETERMINED BUT WE'RE
FINE WITH YOU KNOW CERTAINLY
HAVING THEM INCLUDED BUT IN
TERMS OF A MEMBER I THINK HAVING
A FISHING GAME -- DEPARTMENT
REPRESENTATIVE ON THE AS IN A
PUBLIC AGENCY MAKE UP MAKES A
LOT OF SENSE AND AND THAT'S WHAT
WE OUR RESPECTIVE.
STAFFS THAT THING AND WE WORKED
OUT I GUESS I'D I WOULD POINT
OUT THAT.
A QUESTION REPRESENTS
REPRESENTATIVE IS IS IN THE
STATE AGENCY AS I JUST THINK FOR
THE OTHER MEMBERS TO WEIGH IN --
I'M FIGHTING TAKING THAT -- BUT
IT IS A STATE AGENCY ONE OF THE
REASONS WE COMPROMISED ON THAT
WAS.
THE BECAUSE THE DEPARTMENT OF
BOATING AND WATERWAYS IS UNDER
THE OPS US THIS IS -- PARKS AND
THE PARKS DEPARTMENT.
SO CENTER YEAH I'M JUST SIMPLY
IF IT IF IT WORKS IF IT HELPS
THE BILL FOR MAKES IT BETTER
THAN -- I'M ALL FOR IT AS WELL.
CAN I WOULD -- WHOEVER QUIRK
WITH.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA STOP RIGHT HERE.
IT'S CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
BROUGH SOMEBODY.
DONE.
HERE THAT HERE WELCOME PRESENT
HERE ALLEN.
ARCHULETA ARCH LETTER HERE
PORCHES BRADFORD.
BRADFORD HERE CHIANG CHING HERE
GALGIANI GLAZER.
GLAZER HERE HEALTH WEST OF HERE
PUESTO HEAR JON'S.
CHANCE HERE NIELSEN.
PORTANTINO RUBIO WIENER
[inaudible]
WIENER HERE.
SO MISTER CHAIR TO BE CLEAR
WE'RE FINE WITH FISHING GAME
BEING INCLUDED AS ONE OF THE
STATE AGENCIES.
ARE THE VOTING FOLKS AS YOU
MENTION ARE UNDER PARKS AND REC
SO THEY'LL BE REPRESENTED IN
THAT RESPECT [inaudible]
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
WE GET A MOTION -- ANY
DISCUSSION.
OKAY WE CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
FILE ITEM THIRTEEN A. B..
ELEVEN ELEVEN MOTION IS DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
DODD.
DODD I WILL TRY WILK AYE ALLEN.
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA HI FORGES
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I'D CHANGE THAT CHANGE
HI GALGIANI.
GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE HILL.
HILL HI WEST OF WITH SO I JONES.
JONES I NIELSEN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER AYE.
THAT BILLS ON CALL.
WELL VERY MUCH TEN VOTES A BILLS
ON CALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS THE WITNESSES -- YEAH.
THAT ETHNICITY THAN I DO CAN WE
ARE ONE MORE BILL.
SO WHAT I'M GONNA DO -- AB
SEVENTEEN FIFTY FOUR FOR JONES
SAWYER BECAUSE HE MAY NEVER MAKE
IT SO -- ALL PASSED THE GAVEL TO
THE VICE CHAIR.
THANK YOU.
FOR OKAY MISTER CHAIR --
PRESENTING AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY
FOUR FOR MISTER CHAIR IF I MAY
ANNOUNCES FIRST SO WE'RE TO GET
NOW ITEM SEVENTEEN BY JONES
SAWYER THE RECOMMENDATION IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE THIS
BILL ENJOYS SUPPORT SUPPORT.
PROCEED THIS BILL REQUIRES A
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES TO ESTABLISH THE
CALIFORNIA OLYMPIC.
AND PARALYMPIC PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMAND -- TO FACILITATE THE
PLANNING RESOURCES MANAGEMENT
DELIVERY SAFETY AND SECURITY.
AT THE TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT
OLYMPIC AND PARALYMPIC GAMES IN
LOS ANGELES -- WE HE'S ACCEPTED
THE AMENDMENTS TO ADD A SUNSET
TO THIS.
AND I BELIEVE WE HAVE -- A
WITNESS IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBER SYLVIA
SOLUTION ON BEHALF OF LA TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT THE ORGANIZING
COMMITTEE FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY
OLYMPIC AND PARALYMPIC GAMES IN
LOS ANGELES -- THE COMMAND
ESTABLISHED BY THIS LEGISLATION
IS BASED ON A MODEL FROM THE
SALT LAKE CITY GAMES.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THE COMMAND
WILL ENSURE EFFECTIVE
COMMUNICATION COORDINATION AND
EXECUTION OF SECURITY PLANNING
AMONG KEY STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
EARLY YEARS LEADING UP TO YOU TO
THE GAMES WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
ANY SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
SINGAPORE BACK TO TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS SENATOR ARCHULETA YES --
THANK YOU CENTER FOR PRESENTING
THIS BILL -- THE FACT IS THAT
THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES -- IS
GOING TO BE PARTICIPATING IN THE
OLYMPIC GAMES PART OF THAT WILL
pA GREAT OPPORTUNTY SO I WOULD
BE HONORED IF YOU'D HAVE ME AS A
CO CHAIR.
AND ALSO -- I WANT TO TELL YOU
THAT -- THE CITY REVERE.
AS A LARGE AREA THAT.
IS UNDER CONSIDERATION SO I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO HAVING YOU
VISIT MY DISTRICT WHEN THIS COME
FORWARD [inaudible]
ASKED.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS
CENTER ARCHULETA ANYONE ELSE.
SEEING NONE OF CARE HAVE A
MOTION FROM CENTER CHIANG.
MR CHERRY MAY CLOSE.
SPEC FULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
AND WITH THAT CLERK CALL THE
ROLL FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN AB
SEVENTEEN FIFTY FOUR MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS DOT.
DODD HI WELCOME HI WILK AYE
ALLEN.
ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA AYE FORGES.
BRADFORD JOHN BRADFORD AYE
CHANGE CHIANG AYE GALGIANI.
GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE HILL.
THE HILL AYE HUESO.
WITH SO I JONES. FIVE JOHN I
NIELSEN.
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
THERE I AT TEN ZERO THAT BILLS
ON CALL.
THIS IS ONE OF CONSENT FOR THEIR
WORK TO THE SERGEANTS.
WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE IN TEN
MINUTES.
SO WE'RE GOING THROUGH GOING
THROUGH THE ROLE NOW.
CAN WE MOVED IN TO GET A MOTION
FOR THE CONSENT.
LET ME SEE HOW QUICKLY I FORGET.
SO IT'S CALL THE ROLL PLEASE GOD.
HI TODD I WILL.
WILK AYE ALLEN ARCHULETA
EXCELLENT AYE BARGES BRADFORD
BRADFORD I CHANGE CHANGE HI
GALGIANI.
GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE HILL HILL AYE HUESO.
WEST SO I JONES.
JONES I NIELSEN.
PORTANTINO.
RUBIO WIENER.
WIENER I IT OPENS.
GO THROUGH THE ROLE [inaudible]
RIGHT.
OKAY A FILE ITEM NUMBER -- ONE
AB -- THIRTY EIGHT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD BE HAVE A MOTION
MOVED MOTION -- CALLED I AM ONE
AB THIRTY EIGHT MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
DODD.
AYE DODD I WILL WRITE WILK AYE
ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I'D FORGES.
BRADFORD BRADFORD I CHANGE.
CHIANG AYE GALGIANI [inaudible]
PLEASE [inaudible]
GLAZER.
HILL BY HILL AYE WESSEL.
WITH SO I JONES.
JONES NO NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE PORTANTINO
[inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER AYE [inaudible] TEN ONE
TEN TO ONE TEN ONE ON CALL.
I WILL MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
TWO AB ONE THIRTY LOW MAY HAVE A
MOTION.
WITH THAT.
HUESO -- WITH THE PROGRESS
CENTER BRADFORD.
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE ITEM TO AB
ONE THIRTY MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS DOT.
I THOUGHT I WILL HI WILK AYE
ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA ARCHULETA
I'D FORGES.
BRADFORD BRADFORD I CHANGE.
HI CHIANG AYE GALGIANI.
GLAZER GLAZER AYE HILL.
HILL AYE HUESO WEST SO I JONES
I'VE JONES I NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE PORTANTINO
[inaudible]
RUBIO.
WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
SO. TWELVE ZERO ON CALL TWELVE
ZERO THAT SONG CALLED -- ITEM
pWHEN.
MOTION ARE TO LET IT.
ITEM THREE EIGHTY TWO FORTY
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE DOT.
I THOUGHT I WILL NINE WILK AYE
ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA ARCHULETA
I'VE GORGEOUS BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I CHIANG.
CHIANG AYE GALGIANI.
GLAZER GLAZER AYE HILL HILL AYE
HUESO MY SO I JONES JONES I
NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE PORTANTINO.
RUBIO [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER AYE.
AND PHONE CALLS. TWELVE ZERO ON
CALL. TWELVE ZERO THE BILLS ON
CALL NEXT ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE AB FIVE SEVENTY TWO KALRA.
HAVE A MOTION -- MOVED.
OCEAN WILL ITEM FIVE EIGHTY FIVE
SEVEN TWO MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE DODD.
I THOUGHT I WILL HI WILK AYE
ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA ARCHULETA
I'D FORGES BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I CHANGE CHIANG AYE
GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE GLAZER.
HEALTH HELLO AYE WESSEL.
WAS SO I JONES.
JONES NO NIELSEN.
NELSON NO PORTANTINO
[inaudible]
RUBIO.
WIENER I MEAN ARE AYE.
TENDED TO ON CALL TO I CALLED --
NEXT BILL ITEM NUMBER. EIGHT SIX
SIX AB FIVE NINETY FOUR SALAS WE
HAVE A MOTION.
GOOD MOTION GLAZER ITEM SIX
EIGHTY FIVE NINE FOUR MOTION IS
DO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE DOT.
BY DOT I WILL.
WILK AYE ALLEN ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA AYE FORGES
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I CHIANG.
CHIANG AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER GLAZER AYE HILL HILL AYE
WEST SO.
WITH SO I JONES.
JONES I NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE PORTANTINO
[inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER HI [inaudible] THIRTEEN
ZERO ZERO THAT BILLS ON CALL
NEXT ITEM UP -- NUMBER EIGHT AB
SIX FORTY NINE GARCIA.
MOTION.
THIS MOTION BY CENTER BRADFORD
CARDINAL I AM EIGHT AB SIX FOUR
NINE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE DODD.
I THOUGHT I WILL HI WILL GUY
ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA ARCHULETA
I'D FORGES BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I CHANGE.
CHANGE HI GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER GLAZER AYE HILL HILL AYE
HUESO WITH SO I JONES.
JONES I NIELSEN NIELSEN AYE.
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
WIENER.
HI.
FOURTEEN ZERO IT'S FOURTEEN ZERO
THAT BILLS ON CALL.
I WILL MOVED ITEM NUMBER TEN AB
EIGHT FORTY DOLLARS.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY CHIANG.
ITEM TEN EIGHTY EIGHT FORTY
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE DODD.
DODD AYE WILK HI WILK AYE ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA BY GILLETTE
I'D FORGES BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I CHIANG CHING AYE
GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE HILL HILL AYE WEST SO.
WITH SO I JONES.
JONES I NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE.
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
WIENER.
WE ARE I WAS FOURTEEN VOTES ON
CALL.
THE THIRTEEN THIRTEEN THIRTEEN
THIRTEEN BOATS -- NUMBER ELEVEN
AB EIGHT NINE SEVEN ONE SALAS.
MOTION CHIANG CENTER CHIANG --
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE ITEM ELEVEN
EIGHTY NINE SEVEN ONE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE DOT.
HI DODD AYE WILK HI WILK AYE
ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA I SHOULD LET
AYE AYE FORGES BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I CHANGE CHIANG AYE
GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE HILL.
HILL AYE HUESO.
WITH SO I JONES.
JONES I NIELSEN.
NIELSEN HI PORTANTINO.
RUBIO WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER AYE. THIRTEEN ZERO ON
CALL THIRTEEN ZERO BILLS ON CALL.
MOVED TO ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN AB
A LOT WE THAT WE WORK WITH JUST
LEFT THE CALL ON THAT.
AB.
ELEVEN ELEVEN AB ELEVEN ELEVEN
I'M ITEM THIRTEEN AT ELEVEN OF
EMOTIONS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE TEN ZERO ABSENT
MEMBERS ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE FORGES GALGIANI
GALGIANI AYE NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE PORTANTINO RUBIO
[inaudible]
HE TO LEARN MORE THIRTEEN AND
SOME CALL FOR THE LAST THIRTEEN
VOTES ON CALL ITEM NUMBER.
FIFTEEN AB.
THIRTEEN OH EIGHT CUNNINGHAM
EMOTION SO MOVED.
THE MOTION BY SENATOR WILL CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE ITEM FIFTEEN AB
THIRTEEN AWAY MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE DODD.
AYE DODD AYE WILK HI AYE ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I'D FORGES BRADFORD
BRADFORD HI CHIANG CHING AYE
GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE HILL HILL AYE HUESO.
SO I JONES.
JOHN HI NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE PORTANTINO
[inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER AYE. THIRTEEN ZERO THAT
SONG CALLED ZERO THOUGHT CALL
WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON ITEM
NUMBER SEVENTEEN AB SEVENTEEN
FIFTY FOUR ITEM SEVENTEEN AB
SEVENTEEN FIFTY FOUR MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE TEN ZERO APPS MEMBERS ALLEN.
ALLEN I FORGES GALGIANI GALGIANI
AYE NIELSEN.
NIELSEN HI PORTANTINO.
RUBIO.
THE BILL HAS. THIRTEEN THIRTEEN
VOTES STILL ON CALL -- WILL GO
BACK TO THE CONSENT NOT CALLING
TO PLEASE.
WENT DOWN TO HAVE.
ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN.
ALLEN I GALGIANI.
SORRY FOR JUST GALGIANI GALGIANI
AYE NIELSEN AYE NIELSEN AYE
PORTANTINO.
RUBIO.
OKAY.
YOURSELF THAT'S THIRTEEN SO.
WE WANT CAN WE FIND OUT IS --
CENTER RUBIO DUTY [inaudible]
THANKS.
THAT'S RIGHT SO I JUST A GAS
RANGES [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible] ONE ONLINE
.
THE START OF THE INFORMATION
SAID AND THEN MOVE THROUGH THE
CALENDAR.
CONSENT CALENDAR ABSENT MEMBERS
GORGEOUS PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE FIFTEEN ZERO FIFTEEN
ZERO THE ROLES CLOSE.
ITEM ONE A. B. THIRTY EIGHT
MOTIONS YOU PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE KERN
BOTH TEND.
TO ONE ABSENT MEMBERS FORGES.
GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO
[inaudible]
RUBIO AYE [inaudible] THIRTEEN
ONE AT THIRTEEN ONE THAT BILLS
OUT.
ITEM TO AB ONE THIRTY MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE TWELVE TO ZERO APPS MEMBERS
GORGEOUS.
GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE PORTANTINO.
TINO AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE FIFTEEN TWO FIFTEEN
ZERO BILLS OUT.
ITEM THREE EIGHTY TWO FORTY
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE TWELVE TWO ZERO ABSENT
MEMBERS GORGEOUS GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO.
REVIEW HI FIFTEEN FIFTEEN ZERO
THAT BILLS OUT.
ITEM FIVE AB FIVE SEVEN TWO
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE TENDED TO ABSENT MEMBERS
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO I RUBIO.
RUBIO HI BILLS OUT.
TWELVE TO TWO ITEM SIX AB FIVE
NINE FOUR MOTION IS YOU HAVE TO
BE RATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE THIRTEEN ZERO
ABSENT MEMBERS GORGEOUS.
PORTANTINO.
I PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO.
REVIEWED BY. FIFTEEN ZERO ITEM
EIGHTY SIX FOUR NINE OCEAN IS
YOU HAVE TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE KERN VOTE THIRTEEN
ZERO APPS MEMBERS GORGEOUS
[inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
RUBIO.
RUBIO HI FOURTEEN ZERO SOUTH --
I DON'T THINK THAT PORTANTINO
HORSES.
THIRTEEN WHAT'S THAT.
HE'S NOT BUILDINGS.
YEAH SO HOW MANY VOTES THAT
FORTY FORTY FORTY VOTE OKAY.
ITEM TEN EIGHTY EIGHT FORTY
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE THIRTEEN ZERO ASSN MEMBERS
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
PORTANTINO. NINETEEN OH HI RUBIO.
I ITEM TEN AB.
EIGHT FORTY RUBIO I FOURTEEN
ZERO THAT.
I'M SORRY. FIFTEEN ZERO ZERO
THAT BILLS OUT.
ITEM ELEVEN EIGHTY NINE SEVEN
ONE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
BOTH THIRTEEN ZERO ABSENT
MEMBERS GORGEOUS.
PORTANTINO.
TINA I RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE FIFTEEN VOTES THAT
BILLS OUT.
I AM THIRTEEN AB ELEVEN ELEVEN
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
BOTH THIRTEEN ZERO ASK MEMBERS
BURGESS.
PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE FIFTEEN VOTES THAT
FILLS OUT ITEM FIFTEEN EIGHTY
THIRTEEN AWAY MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTE THIRTEEN ZERO ASKED
MEMBERS BARGES [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
RUBIO I FOURTEEN FOURTEEN VOTES
THAT BILLS OUT.
ITEM SEVENTEEN AB SEVENTEEN
FIFTY FOUR MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE THIRTEEN
ZERO ASKED MEMBERS FOR JESS
[inaudible] SEVENTY SIX SIXTEEN
WE GO BACK TO CAN WE GO BACK TO
FIFTEEN AND DO THAT AGAIN PLEASE.
JUST TO CALL THE THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
AB THIRTEEN OH EIGHT MOTIONS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
ABSENTMEMBERS GORGEOUS
[inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
RUBIO NOW.
I DON'T KNOW. THIRTEEN ONE
THIRTEEN ONE THE BILLS OUT.
ITEM SEVENTEEN AB SEVENTEEN
FIFTY FOUR MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE THIRTEEN ZERO
ABSENT MEMBERS GORGEOUS
[inaudible]
PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO I RUBIO.
RUBIO I WAS OUT FIFTEEN VOTES.
THAT CONCLUDES THE BUSINESS
BEFORE THE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS COMMITTEE THIS
MEETING IS ADJOURNED
[inaudible]
NO